dans ses rangs
lacker grand comme ça
rappelle dominique au pied ses 60 ans
générant en bretagne il ya à la chapelle
launay dans l'arrondissement de saint
nazaire
une mariée qu'une réunionnais tué trois
enfants trois garçons et puis on s'est
vite l'idée d'acheter un terrain
agricole à l'intérêt sincère et de
m'installer comme agriculteur de 35 ans
à côté de ça ben je mets ma passion
c'est la musique
entre on appelle notre musique la
musique créole au celtic 1 donc il ya ce
côté là il ya le côté humaniste quand
les paroles de renaissance ont toujours
un lien avec l'identité refoulé avec les
situations difficiles étant jeune il
avait pour rêve de se lancer dans
l'humanitaire x car il a toujours eu
cette volonté de d'aider les plus
faibles
son objectif à lui céder aussi l'époque
de mettre son temps à à la disposition 9
la petite cheminée e5000 fait cuire le
cari pas de cochon le meilleur car il
pas que sont la réunion et ou noir
attention les bombes
ma personne j'en ai moi c'est bon alors
qu'on raconte
franchement c'est un homme adorable chef
rien on est heureux c'est quand les
autres heureux si nous si nous les
heureux ont fermé chez nous c'est
l'égoïsme pas bon c'est quand les eaux
se remettre mon plaisir c'est d'aller
par exemple à madagascar et plus de voir
les gens contents nous recevoir il ça
qu'on le ramène à la fois de la musique
du bonheur de l'argent bien sûr au
courant survivre et pour faire les
équipements etc c'est ça